welcome to another gamespot news update
I'm Maxwell McGee and bioware has just
released the official cover art for
their upcoming role-playing game dragon
age inquisition the art depicts the hero
of the game the Inquisitor standing on a
rocky cliff twisting a hand upward the
shape of a dragon with outstretched
wings has formed in the negative space
easily seen when the image is inverted
the image was tweeted from the official
Dragon Age twitter with the caption they
say only the Inquisitor has the power to
stop it at this point it is unknown who
they are or what it is and why it must
be stopped mud there you go the art was
created purposefully so that the gender
of the hero is not obvious creative
director Mike Laidlaw said on twitter an
uncertain gender was absolutely intended
it's wherever you want to roll
essentially that makes sense games like
Skyrim or mass effect pick a generic
version of the hero that many players
characters don't resemble at all so this
approach to the cover art will be more
relatable to different players the only
other thing we know about Dragon Age
Inquisition is that it's coming out
sometime this fall of course you can
catch all the latest updates on the game
by heading on over to gamespot com